hello everyone and welcome to the
greatest day in the history of online
chess okay i'm maybe exaggerating a
little bit but not all that much today
we will have the big christmas arena
unleashes and a lot of very strong
players have registered here you can see
uh only only some of the names these are
the top ten so leading the pack we have
daniel narodicy then the penguin uh
cloud9 andrew tang uh the then in third
place there's uh alexander botanic
alireza also joined sergey shigalko
international master mad pro grand
master azado 25 uh not sure who he is
but some of the uh people have been
saying that that uh that could be doable
then we have uh tsm ftxh that is uh
hikaru nakamura making his first grand
appearance on leeches then we have
vladimir 9000 i think that's uh
andreikin uh russian grandmaster and
then
uh swadmivco who also i don't know who
uh he is but also maybe that could be do
both i know so people have been saying
that someone in the top ten here is
dubois but these are only the top ten
and you can see the top ten uh here are
uh all rated above three thousand so
yeah it's gonna be a great event uh
we'll see if magnus will join but even
if he joins uh he will probably join
under a a different name so he could be
playing uh
you know under under uh
uh some sort of a mysterious alias and
okay most of the people joined here
because of the big prize and the magnus
um will not join for the money so if he
joins uh it will be because he wants to
beat uh well all of these very strong
players uh so as hikaru doesn't usually
play on leeches i made a limit you have
to play at least 50 rated games in order
to be able to join the tournament so you
know not everyone can just make an
account and use an engine to cheat if
you want to cheat you have to work for
your meal and play at least 50 rated
games which is not a problem but i'm
sure uh the deletions bots will pick up
on any suspicious play if any happens so
hikaru played this the the 50 games
required and i'm going to show you guys
one of the
nice games that he played against our
mysterious person here the foreplay of
course i have to wear the hoodie as uh
well uh we have a hoodie guy in the in
the video uh so let's uh check it out
it's a very very nice aggressive game
very much in hikaru style as well the
king's side pawns will be pushed and
foreplay is rated around 2750 on
leachate so also a very strong player so
let's check it out uh mr foreplay uh
opens with knight to f3 we have the red
opening and hikaru goes for g6 we have
e3 and now bishop to g7 we have d4
and now d6 sort of a modern defense type
of opening we have bishop to e2 and
knight to f6 both players castle
and now b3 they're ready to put his
bishop on this long diagonal to counter
hikaru strong bishop on g7 might beat
the d7 preparing to strike in the center
with e5 and bishop to b2 and already a
very interesting moment hikaru pushes e5
and he's basically giving up a pawn uh
which could be captured for example
captures captures capture so let's say
captures captures and now well whatever
you want to do move the queen play
bishop to f5 so white can win a pawn
here but interestingly uh the position
has been reached before some people grab
the pawn some people don't i'm sure
there's a very good reason why uh why
not uh grab the pawn even though the
engine says it's okay uh so here instead
we have uh
c4 by white uh grabbing the center it
makes sense to play like this because
you will be playing on the queen side a
lot and now hikaru advances the pawn all
the way to e4 so knight after d2 and now
rook to e8 we have to
defend our pawn knight to c3 adding more
pressure to the pawn you will play queen
to c2 and then really pile up on the
pawn and now hikaru does uh well what he
does best he starts expanding his king
side and he will try to attack white's
king whereas white will try to attack on
the queen side and now there are some
games where queen to c2 was played it
makes sense you want to go after d4 pawn
but white starts with b4 immediately he
wants to start his queenside expansion
as soon as possible and of course it is
as of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game hikaru continues pushing we
have h4 and white prevents any further
pushes by playing h3 but okay this
prevents the black pawn from reaching h3
but it also gives black a target if uh
you know things get crazy so knight f8
we have to get this knight into the game
as well maybe knight h7 to g5 and rook
to e1 uh we have knight h to h7 like we
said and now white grabs more space with
d5 now a4 b5 c5 anything can be played
here so a6 by hikaru and now queen to c2
putting pressure on this e4 pawn and
hikaru defends it with knight to g5 also
putting a lot of pressure on white's
king's side so bishop to f1 this bishop
will nicely defend the d spawns and
knight to d7 now hikar wants to bring
his knight over to e5 and that will make
it even more dangerous because then all
sorts of sacrifices will be possible
as you'll see so here uh the question is
can you capture the pawn now you are
attacking it three times well the answer
is still no if you capture it at night
let's say let's say an id captures on e4
we're gonna capture this and if knight
captures we just capture the bishop and
black wins a piece queen captures we're
going to capture the knight and we're up
a knight so of course completely winning
so white cannot go for that he plays
knight to e2 and now he carried trades
bishops captures captures and now knight
to e5 so black having a firm grip on the
position but uh white doesn't care and
this is perfectly fine for white white
should in fact continue playing on the
queen side this is uh usually how these
positions are played knights to d4 and
now queen to ef6 bringing more firepower
into the game queen to c2 now uh going
forward for the pawn here but bishop to
f5 nicely defending and offering uh the
doubling of the pawns but this doesn't
really do all that much we're just gonna
capture it now this is just wonderful
for black
so instead we have rook 8 to c1 and now
again preparing to push those pawns on
the queen side and rook to e7 and now
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game we have a4 and hikaru plays a5
he wants to undermine white's uh uh
advanced pawn structure here and here
you might play b5 but then you have a
hole in c5 this is kind of what hikaru
wants to do so white ignores this he
continues pushing we have c5 and hikaru
now captures on b4 he shatters the white
spawn structure here c capture c
captures and now queen to b3
uh so the b4 pawn is attacked but hikaru
goes after the a4 pawn so bishop to a4
attacking the spawn queen captures on b4
rook captures on a4 attacking the queen
we have queen back to b2 and now the
position is as it is uh but hikaru is
completely winning here but there is
only one move that wins in the game so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this idea while i give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being a great
shatterer of white's king side and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course bishop captures on
h3 that's the good stuff and the bishop
cannot be captured because well for one
it really weakens the f3 square but not
only that if you capture this just root
captures on d4 and that's it it doesn't
matter if you capture with the queen
then look at this uh that's a beautiful
square for the night so of course we're
going to put a knight there knight f3
check and after one night captures we
just deliver another check and pick up
the queen and it doesn't help if you
instead of capturing with a queen
capture with the pawn pretty much the
same thing knight checks we're going to
capture with the knight knight captures
with checking h1 now queen f4 and you
are getting checkmated that's it so of
course bishop captures an h3 isn't
really uh a gambit or or an offering or
it's just a piece you cannot capture so
here we have queen b5 attacking the rook
here and he just moves the rook back or
rather not moves the rook back he just
goes bishop back to d7
attacks the queen defends the rook queen
captures on b7 and now hikaru continues
pushing with h3 really a powerful king
side attack queen to b8 with check king
g7 and now rook the c7
white has no more chances of defending
his king side he now has to organize
some sort of a counter attack but it
doesn't seem like it's uh well a very
likely scenario so here h captures on g2
threatening the bishop bishop captures
and now bishop back to h3 and here you
could capture or play whatever but it
doesn't really matter you are completely
lost here bishop to h1 was played and
here we simply have rook captures on d4
this was always in the position but now
hikaru plays at simply removing one of
the knights from defending the f3 square
we have e captures on d4 and now knight
e to f3 with check for king everything
knight captures on f3 we have knight
captures and f3 with check and he was in
this position on move 35 that uh
foreplay our mysterious uh
gentleman here uh resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
interestingly you might think okay let's
capture with the queen and then deliver
a smothered mate but you would be very
wrong because after the bishop captures
the queen the h1 square becomes
available for the king and the king has
the h1 square to escape to even though
all of these squares are covered you
know in quick time formats you could
make a mistake like this so be careful
so here like i said knight captures an
f3 was played and here he resigns
because the only movie is bishop
captures and after queen captures
there's no defense against queen to g2
checkmate
so uh that's one of the games uh he carl
played in preparation for this big event
uh
something we can expect today so
hopefully all of you guys can can make
it it's gonna start 8 p.m uh central
european time uh it's gonna last two
hours and we're gonna have uh some great
chess being played um i'm gonna try and
uh show uh some of the games of course
there are too many games um
to show all the interesting ones but
we're gonna try to cover uh you know uh
at least uh
uh some of the top games and um
of course i will be reading the chat as
usual you guys are welcome to and you
know ask questions and whatever you
whatever you guys feel like we're gonna
have a good time uh like i said really
hope you guys can make it this is gonna
be a wonderful event and uh well really
really glad that it's happening uh so
yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh hikaru makes his grand
appearance on lee chess i would like to
thank weaver sky music emmanuel freitas
duncan weincall william fuller and the
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything that's happening in the chess
world and checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
thank you all i will see you soon and
see you see you later today in the grand
christmas arena
see you soon